often wisdom to be found in a good book
and if your first thought is we just
don't have time to read them
well podcast host and mom zippy Owen
says we really do she's made it her
mission to get people reading by
introducing them to the latest authors
their works and even their stories not
on the pages and in the midst of this
pandemic she's found brand new ways to
do it hey I'm the creator and host of
the podcast moms don't have time to read
books you heard correctly moms don't
have time to read books a podcast led by
this mother of four I'd like use the
book it's like look at all the doggies
proving otherwise that's a catchy title
but moms are finding time to read books
moms do find time to read books
sometimes a lot of mom said oh my gosh
you've inspired me to read again there's
just so much else competing for her time
and attention but there's something
about reading so fundamental to being
human it certainly is for zippy Owens
and always has been a lover of books and
their authors even as a kid which led to
a unique list of childhood idols but I
was a little girl I used to write
letters
my mom would help me go to the back of
the books and find the publisher address
and I would write letters to the author
and she would I held it for me when I
was 11 years old I went to the plaza for
tea with this author who shares the name
with me zippy O'Neal fan mail wasn't all
that Owens wrote I've been writing my
whole life since I was nine years old
and my grandfather published a little
miniature book of my stories it
published an essay and 17 when I was 16
years old I'd love to write I wouldn't
do it all the time
writing is how I sort out the craziness
in my mind the essays that I write I
know can help other people I lost my
best friend over 9/11 and she was my
college roommate and best friend and I
immediately wrote about it for my
business school paper and I remember my
classmates saying like how could you do
that you just like put yourself out
there like it didn't even occur to me
not to write that but I think that the
things that I like to share are things
that everybody is thinking and feeling
which brings us back to the podcast how
is food medicine oh I'm obsessed I do
think food as medicine the title was
originally pegged for a compilation of
essays on
parenting but a friend and fellow author
nudged Owens in a different direction
she said you should start a podcast and
I was like what's a podcast you didn't
even know a podcast what not really I
literally went home and my husband Kyle
and I sat on the couch we were like
where is the podcast button podcast they
don't understand what this is so we
found the podcast button I started
listening to a lot of other ones I
googled everything turns out it was
gonna be really easy not expensive low
risk so I thought I don't know I guess
I'll try it
Owens turn to the familiar for the focus
of her podcast books more specifically
authors I've had on a range of authors
from Anne Lamott Meg Wolitzer Jennifer
whiner Evangeline Lilly who wrote a
children's book series and was on lost
thanks so much for doing this one of the
first people I interviewed was Andre
Agassi who wrote the book open which was
one of my favorite books you weren't at
this point an experienced podcaster I
didn't know what I was doing but again I
was just trying to talk to him I really
had things I wanted to know about him
and tennis in his life and the writing I
did it on the phone but I was drenched
in sweat like so nervous asking him all
these questions how did you find
coaching versus playing it was
interesting you know it's when I played
I never felt pressure at all I was never
about pressure it was I felt stress I
remember running down stairs after
everything like I did two years later
which was when we first caught up with
Owens last fall she had hundreds of
podcasts under her belt and an offline
community to go along with her online
footprint thanks to live author events
and book fairs like this one she's
someone who is the real literary citizen
I love that that word Michelle Phil gate
is the editor of the essay collection
what my mother and I don't talk about
she connects readers with writers I
think that her podcast is crucial for
allowing for curation in an age where we
are inundated with
and now in this age of social distancing
Owens continues to connect readers and
writers I was like I have to help all
the authors you have books coming out
who aren't gonna have book tour because
the previous weeks leading up to this I
had talked to a number of authors who
were getting very concerned what about
my books coming out what can I do
Bowens immediately began curating new
release reading lists for sites like
bookshop org where people can buy titles
online from local stores was it in fair
shape
she created a virtual book club
including author participation and then
turned to social media given writers a
platform with daily Instagram live
interviews it's just such a nice escape
because we're not only talking about the
pandemic we're talking about the
subjects of people's books and the
structure and the story and all these
emotions that maybe we're not we don't
have the luxury of feeling at this exact
moment I think it provides an escape for
everybody that includes Owens who says
the escape helps her stay focused she
even moved up the launch of a planned
online magazine of essays we found time
another opportunity to escape it's on
the five things that I thought moms
don't have time for the most mom soon
have time to read work out eat have sex
and breathe and in those categories
I have author's write essays about those
experiences but even with all of the new
platforms Owens remains dedicated to the
one that started it all a podcast I'm
thinking now do moms have even less time
to read books I think less time we are
all in this together it doesn't matter
mom dad anybody grandparent I think you
have to really be conscious about saving
a place for reading as a form of mental
health right now and not feeling guilty
about it I think there's guilt
associated with lounging on a couch and
reading a book like you're just doing
nothing but it's the opposite of that if
you just open up a book and spend even
ten minutes you'll get into someone
else's head in mind and you'll just get
out of your house I mean right now we
can't even go anywhere so I like to open
up books and transport myself to another
location
and pretty soon you'll be able to open
up a zippy Owens children's book
princess charming will be the title of
it and for podcast today Jeff I'm going
to recommend it even though I have not
heard it yet it's with Alicia Keys okay
we'll try that one out yeah mom's
definitely have you have even less time
right now they are all of us superstars
and by the way we're gonna feature
another great book
we love featuring books another great
one coming up next week Dana good piece
good update to another woman having an
impact now if